[Music]
so it's a king alright now we all know
what we're here for
we had a watch the WBC heavyweight
champion of the world defend his title
that's
Deontay Wilder versus dominique brazil
now at first glance you thought that you
know this fight was just a filler fight
to get on the ante wilder closer to
either Tyson Fury or Anthony Joshua who
is the um next heavyweight champion of
the world the titles of split Anthony
Joshua has the remaining belts which is
the WBA IBF and probably the WBO but uh
the prestige belt resides in the US of A
in the hands of Deontay Wilder so I'm
gonna give you the road going up to the
fight you know we don't usually do this
here but we're gonna give you the road
going up to the fight going into this
fight Dominic Brazil and Deontay Wilder
had an altercation believe it was two
years ago and that altercation led to a
lot of death threats a lot of true
animosity between both camps now who we
are here present day and we have this
fight so when the fight was made and
Dominic Brazil made itself to mandatory
to fight the heavyweight champion of the
world
Deontay Wilder I automatically assume
that you know we would be Oh a whitewash
a regular fight um then I look back on
the fight tape of Anthony Joshua versus
Dominic Brazil and I noticed and I
noticed from the early on in the fight
the Dominic Brazil presented a couple of
challenges for Anthony Joshua his long
right hand his jab his ability to fight
so
I dig deeper into Dominic Brazil and
it's a former Olympian you know guys you
know what I say about those Olympians
those guys are tough out you know 100
percent there to fight they have seen
all the styles in the world and they are
pedigree they have stuff that you have
to worry about and you have to fear so
leading up to the fight you had Deontay
Wilder saying a lot of disparaging
comments towards uh Dominic Brazil that
he wanted to kill him dad you know this
is the only sport that you can catch a
body in the ring and for some weird
reason the WBC investigated their own
champion for words that he said
pertaining to what he felt like he could
do in the ring to the Challenger this is
getting way out of hand guys this is
just a build-up to a fight
I heard Mike Tyson tell you after a
fight he wanted to shatter the guy's
nose bones with him break into his brain
I heard Mike Tyson said you know you
wanted to be people kids and I've heard
other fighters make the same amount of
comments all right we all know when we
danced this dance of death inside that
ring and he blows your last blow so
going through to the fight you have to
understand that it was definitely a
possibility that things can happen all
right so not at the weigh-in happen not
if these guys are ready to go and then
the mix made weight both for the boom
the heavyweights of course Dominick
Brazil I believe is 255 the Challenger
and 225 for the heavyweight champion of
the world
I expect this fight to play out in this
manner now but you have to look at is a
such psychological aspect to this fight
that's underlining everything
Deontay Wilder has been extremely out of
character now normally he is that
braggadocious that uh strong imposing
figure going into a fight but this seems
to be a level of intimidation that I've
seen from him that's us a notch above a
little bit more and I worry going into
this fight that that is his undoing you
ever wanted to get us something so bad
that you couldn't see the forest for the
trees you ever wanted to obtain
something so bad that you made missteps
trying to leap forward to grab it
because it was in your grasp this is my
fair with this fight my fear is the ante
while dispense yourself in a round
trying to eliminate Dominic Brazil and
it's caught get outs box get sidetracked
and this stuff happened this stuff
happens to fighters remember Deontay
Wilder knows nothing but winning and if
any of you guys say well you lost that
fight with Tyson Fury Dan lost lose the
fight sorry was it draw I already told
you I came to the drawer and showed you
how to draw with me this fight here is a
question mark is gonna see if Deontay
Wilder can keep his composure in the
ring
settle down sit on his shots deliver him
in a timely fashion because he's
unorthodox come on guys he's a force of
nature
Dominic Brazil is by the books fight
stole behind a jab right hand the thing
that's working for Dominic Brazil
besides the fact that he's an Olympian
[Music]
Virgil hunter is head trainer Virgil
hunter is a savvy trainer
please mental mind games with his
fighters gets them in the best possible
shape but also allows them and tells
them like it is to see the fight and how
it plays out plays to their strengths
now you may look at Dominic Brazil's
body and believe he's out of shape no
some guys have a softer frame than
others he's in shape this fight is gonna
play out as such I believe Deontay
Wilder comes out and tries to get the
quick fake tail he might get the quick
the quick ko he might get that flash
boom bash knockout might happen or I
might go to way that I think that he
struggles early on until Dominique drops
their legs they're lazy jab for doesn't
bring that right hand up to block the
left hook and Deonte while the blast is
him out of it I expect
Dominic Brazil face to swell up his eyes
usually swell and I expect him to
languish on the ropes and the fight is
stopped either in the seventh or the
eighth round by TKO
this has been combat talking to King old
fully I'm wrong in this whole thing and
it's easy and smooth sailing for the
heavyweight champion as he gets ready to
fight Anthony Joshua the other
heavyweight champion well hey we here
for a fight
what's wrong with a little adversity on
our way to it don't miss out on Gary
Russell jr. fighting on the undercard
Gary Russell jr. is a putting himself in
position to fight javante tank Davis
that is a fight tying in the sea this
has been combat talk with King listen
IOP at 1:00 p.m. tomorrow see if I was
right or wrong shout out to the e3 crew
a couple of more weeks to the next fight
[Music]